if you are traveling 80 miles per hour
how long does it take you to go 80 miles
wait what about the tire turning thing
you were talking about you think that
affects it
it's gotta take at least like 58 minutes
or something
Travis do you consider your wife smart
well she's at school with college Oh
College I thought you're gonna say
middle school
I'm kidding Chelsea now go play outside
while adults talk sure you're an
intelligent woman Chelsea you know what
miles per hour means right yes good
because I have a couple questions for
you
but your answers are funny what's faster
a cheetah going 70 miles per hour or a
car going 70 miles per hour I would say
bull oh I guess I'm gonna have to give
you partial credit
you